des visiteurs étrangers qui manque
cruellement avec la coved 19 le château
de versailles a perdu 80% de son public
on a ouvert en juin en essayant d'ouvrir
le plus tôt possible après 83 jours de
fermeture les faits les étrangers
n'étaient plus là c'est une certitude
mais on a eu en juillet août notamment
une population de visiteurs français un
peu plus ch plus con ce qu'on attendait
au fond les français qui sont peut-être
pas beaucoup partis en vacances on prend
en plus profiter du château malgré ces
touristes français le château enregistre
un déficit d'environ 35 millions d'euros
pas de conséquences financières pour les
1000 salariés du site
mais pour les emplois indirects la
situation est différente on à 83
concessionnaires les concessionnaires
selon des preuves de chiffre d'affaires
et eux donc mais des agents enfin des
employés au chômage partiel ou repousse
des recrutements dont lé les vraies
difficultés économiques
face aux pertes liées à la crise le
château devrait pouvoir compter sur le
plan de relance du gouvernement
87 millions d'euros sur deux ans seront
consacrés au site
mais l'été a permis d'accueillir une
clientèle différente tous les publics
peuvent trouver quelque chose de
différent à versailles et les plus
jeunes peuvent venir un verset sans
s'ennuyer et en faisant des parcours qui
n'ont pas besoin d'être totalement
exhaustif on n'a pas besoin de rester
cinq heures pour visiter la totalité du
château des seuils le château continue
de proposer ces expositions comme celle
à la salle du jeu de paume une période
estivale plutôt mitigé pour de nombreux
sites yvelinois si l'été a été quasi
normal à l'espace rambouillet le musée
d'archéologie nationale accuse une
baisse de fréquentation de 70%